let's talk about evgeny pregosian the
boss of the Wagner group who's been
reported dead
Russian authorities say he was on a jet
that crashed on its way from Moscow to
Saint Petersburg
it happened exactly two months after
pagosian LED his Wagner forces in a
short-lived Mutiny against the Russian
state
there's so much speculation about what
happened and what it could mean here are
three big questions we're left with
let's start with the first one who was
behind it
the private jet was registered to
burgosian there were 10 people listed as
being on board including three crew it
was going from Moscow to St Petersburg
about 30 minutes into the flight the
plane basically dropped out of the sky
everyone on board was killed
we can't rule out that it was an
accident and the Russia Aviation
authorities have launched an
investigation but there's also a lot of
speculation that Foul Play was involved
because of how the plane crashed and
pregosian's notoriety and if that's the
case who would have wanted pragosian
Dead
while potentially Vladimir Putin the
Russian president burgosian's Mutiny in
June was the biggest threat he'd ever
faced to his authority
foreign
at the time Putin appeared to be furious
with burgosian but pretty quickly it
looked like things had been smoothed
over burgosian called off the Mutiny
after about 24 hours in a deal brokered
by the president of Belarus over the
next couple of months it even started
looking like pagosian had been forgiven
and it was business as usual for Wagner
group operations in Africa
is
but just letting go of such a huge
challenge to his power isn't really
Putin's style Putin is someone who
generally thinks that revenge is a dish
best served colds in my experience Putin
is the ultimate Apostle of payback so
there's a theory that the Russian state
with Putin's backing played a role in
bringing down the plane it's absolutely
no coincidence ever since the aborted
Mutiny in late June in which he
embarrassed Vladimir Putin he's been a
Marked Man for about 24 hours after the
crash there was no response from the
Kremlin but then President Putin
expressed condolences and praised
pagosian as a talented businessman I
foreign
[Music]
plane include that Ukraine could have
somehow been involved some Russian
commentators have suggested this
although president zielinski denies it
remember pregosian's Wagner forces have
led a lot of the fighting for Russia and
Ukraine up until that Mutiny in June it
was a terrorist attack of Ukrainian
authorities because for Ukrainian
authorities
was a very big enemies I don't think
President Putin is somehow involved in
that because if Putin wanted to get rid
of privation he had all the legal
grounds to put him in jail for Life the
Kremlin spokesman Dmitry peskov has also
called speculation of Putin's
involvement in the pregosian plane crash
an absolute lie
so when it comes to who was behind the
plane crash we may never know the full
truth our next question is what
pagosian's death could mean for Putin
does it make him stronger or weaker well
again we need to go back to that Mutiny
in June one way of looking at it is that
pagosian's death removes a threat to
Putin to the extent he was weakened two
months ago he's now
reinforcing himself as the strong man
and making it clear to those around him
that if they cross the Tsar there will
be consequences
it's an extremely powerful message to
send obviously to those who oppose a
Chromebook it comes on the same day that
the head of the Russian airs race forces
Sergey serovic and the general who was
close to pregocion was dismissed but
there's another way of seeing this too
that pagosian's death might be a
symbolic victory for Putin but it
doesn't actually solve his problems the
economy is under pressure the war in
Ukraine is going badly and burgosian's
death could even make divisions in the
Russian military worse is the is the end
of the political instability in Russia
not a good look to be shooting down if
it is or blowing up or probably the most
likely scenarios here
um private private jets over your own
territory our last question is what will
happen to the Wagner group that pagosian
led the group is a PMC a private
military company but it's basically been
seen as a kind of arm of the Russian
State and has been involved in many
different conflicts including Syria and
Ukraine but Africa is where Wagner
really honed its business model the
Wagner group is not just a mercenary
group it's also a Logging Company it's
also an information communication
company it's it's um it's minings but
it's also serving a purpose for these uh
governments in the region that seek
alternative Partnerships to uh the West
evgeny pagosan Was The Man Behind all of
that and who could replace him is not
clear at all especially because another
senior Wagner leader Dmitry uken was
also reported that he was on the same
plane
so will the group survive it seems that
the
the Wagner group has been decapitated
and that means well if not the end of
the Wagner group with the serious very
serious handicap for their further
activities it may be end of the end of
that name first
um it may turn out to be the end of its
senior commanders
um but I think it's a useful tool that
works hand in hand with um the Russian
Russian Foreign Service in the military
a foreign military
um Special Forces I don't think that's
going to go away but but I think control
of it may change but also remember that
pagodin commanded thousands of soldiers
who were known for being disciplined and
loyal to him
a memorial to him has appeared outside
the Wagner building in St Petersburg and
following the news of the plane crash
the post on a Wagner linked telegram
Channel called him a hero and a Russian
Patriot and said there were people
behind it who were traitors to Russia so
how will all those mercenaries now react
one would assume that Putin is trying to
regain control of the Wagner group but
it's a it's a far-flung organization
with some capability
um and uh it'll be everyone will be
watching to see if they go Rogue
if you want to know more about yevgeny
progosian check out our start here
episode on the Wagner group we've also
done one on Vladimir Putin
[Music]